[Music]
this is exciting I love this job so so
much I really do love this job don't get
me wrong but I recently went to the
movies and once again became completely
envious of the old guy that tears the
tickets never taken a moment to be
envious of the old guy tearing the
tickets how sweet how sweet is that like
nobody expects anything from ticket
tearing guy first of all he's just
tearing tickets second row he's old
everybody's just proud even showed up
like hey look Gus is at it again
what I'm saying is only end jobs are the
best I envy the old man job that I call
him exit level positions they're great
low stress easy even when you're
up everybody loves you just like Jasper
you just let nine kids into the lego
movie for free you're doing a great job
all you got to do is stand there and
tear tickets that's the whole job he
doesn't even have to know anything about
the theater he's just like theater 13
that's upstairs
there's no obsess the teenage ticket
terror is narconon I'm like mr. Stevens
he's telling people you tell people
there's an upstairs shut up he built
this country
oh manjeong another unmanned job I'd
love to have as a greeter you know like
at Walmart I think I'd be great great
greeting it's the same thing as ticket
airing except you don't even have to
tear tickets the whole gig is just
staying around the front door saying hi
as people into the store that's great I
feel like I'd be great at that big happy
golden retriever face you can't tell me
you don't want to see this big happy
face on your way to buy pajama pants
[Applause]
it's all behind me we can't just have
that job you got to earn that job you
know I mean my bones are dense I got to
spend 30 years even boxes in the back
then get paid to say hello you know what
I mean work your way into it why didn't
that work to mean I looked at Joe was it
me
Joe's one of our darkest writers like
say whenever there's a joke where I'm
like and I'm first in the mouse he's
like we're about to find out if you can
say fisting the mouse
on TBS but the greatest old man job of
all has to be half-assed mall Santa
Claus this is the culmination the zenith
of old man jobs the mall Santa sitting
on a throne in your own village that
they erected in your honor like you're
the Emperor of the mall little kids
sitting on your lap they think you're
Santa you forgot that you're not they're
leaning in whispering their hopes and
dreams filling your heart with light and
you're encouraged to gain weight and be
jolly
that's a job requirement hey Stevenson
got a Cinnabon and be happy you son of a
[Applause]
[Music]